13,3 milliards c'est le déficit de la
sécurité sociale en 2012 la diminution
des recettes avec un nombre de
travailleurs en chute libre n'est pas la
seule explication depuis le début de
l'année une politique de contrôle des
dépenses plus rigoureuse a été mise en
place aujourd'hui c'est la caisse
primaire d'assurance maladie des
yvelines qui a décidé de lancer cette
opération de répression contre les
fraudes et les abus invité ce soir à
killeen francisco bonsoir le directeur
de la régulation de la cpam 78 j'aime
déjà j'aimerais juste que vous nous
précise y est la différence entre un
abus une fraude
et puis une faute c'est pas tout à fait
la même chose il ya différents stades
tout à fait donc ce qu'il faut ce qui
est important c'est qu'effectivement
l'abus est un usage excessif des biens
de la collectivité dont par exemple une
prescription excessive d'arrêt de
travail pour un médecin
la faute est justement par exemple pour
un assuré le fait de ne pas respecter
les horaires de présence
alors que la fraude on est vraiment dans
l'intention de nuire avec souvent
parfois des actions qui sont menées en
bande organisée et/ou les outils de la
répression se mettre en oeuvre
aujourd'hui pour être bien clair on fait
de la prévention la répression ont fait
les deux c'est une mission d'assurance
maladie tout d'abord informer
accompagner nos publics que ce soit les
assurer ou les professionnels de santé
si parfois les messages ne sont pas
entendus ou compris au milieu en
pratique
effectivement il ya des actions de
répression et vous dites justement
renforcer cette répression vous avez de
nouveaux outils de nouveaux moyens pour
agir
alors tout d'abord nous avons
spécialisés des équipes dédiées sur le
sujet donc à une équipe aujourd'hui de
18 collaborateurs avec notamment cinq
enquêteurs assermentés clip qui sont sur
le terrain mais c'est vrai que là ce
qu'on pense que nous souhaitons faire
principalement c'est effectivement une
information une compagnie de nos publics
derrière ou quand une fois ces équipes
n'interviennent que dans des cas très
particuliers arrêts de travail abusifs
fausses déclarations vous avez mentionné
quelques uns des exemples tout à l'heure
quels sont les cas qui reviennent le
plus souvent
alors en ce qui concerne les assurés
c'est effectivement ces cas là donc
c'est aussi des fraudes
à la cmu notamment le fait de se faire
ouvrir des droits alors que normalement
nous on n'est pas bénéficiaire
en ce qui concerne les professionnels de
santé c'est globalement plus diversifiés
notamment des facturations de d'actes
non réalisés ou bien un usage un petit
peu plus héberger deux des progrès très
gros gative en termes de de facturation
l'assurance maladie alors comment se
passe le travail des enquêteurs sur le
terrain reportage d' anthony rech qui a
suivi sébastien gonzalez c'est l'un des
enquêteurs de vos services
monsieur bonjour sébastien bruzzese de
la cpam des yvelines je me permets de
vous contacter pour vérifier les
documents que vous avez concernant le
transport que vous êtes en train
d'effectuer
donc si vous avez la prescription
médicale ce type de contrôle sébastien
gonzalez enquêteurs à la cpam en réalise
presque quotidiennement aux portes des
hôpitaux ou des cliniques au programme
vérification de la prescription médicale
du patient de la présence du macaron
conventionnés sur le pare brise et de la
trousse de soin des éléments
indispensables au remboursement du
transport par la caisse d'assurance
maladie
si le taxi admettant n'a pas la
prescription médicale un moment du
transport
on peut faire un refus lorsqu'il on
transfère la facture par exemple
s'il n'a pas le macaron aussi n'a pas la
trousse de secours
on peut entamer une procédure
conventionnelle un taxi conventionné
prend en charge les clients et est
ensuite remboursée par la sécurité
sociale
pour ce chauffeur le transport
médicalisé représente 30% de son
activité quotidienne
c'est normal parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup d'abus et surtout en ce moment
on parle beaucoup du trou de la sécu
donc normalement il ya pas d'ici là
dessus après
après il ya des règles à respecter l
convention question avec la sécu apporte
seulement le respect qui a participé
depuis 2011 le service de lutte contre
les abus et les fraudes et centralisées
dans cet espace chaque jour 18 agents à
la manière d'un détective privé repère
des fraudes en tous genres arrêt de
travail non respectés fausses
déclarations de revenus pour obtenir des
demandes d aides sociales mais aussi des
actes fictifs des professionnels de
santé
l'exemple qu'on a vu sur quelqu'un qui
avait fraudé sur ses avis d'arrêt de
travail on était quand même monter à 58
milles euros de préjudice sur un
professionnel de santé en général on est
sur une base de 20 à 40 mille euros d'un
nul mais ça peut monter on a eu
l'exemple un infirmier qui a été
condamné pour l'instant première
instance et qui a eu cette somme il rôde
pour la nation
chaque année ce service traite entre 550
et 600 dossiers sur le département
après enquête 70% des sommes à payer
sont récupérées soit plus de un million
deux cent mille euros entendu quelques
chiffres au cours de ce reportage 58
mille euros de préjudice d'un
particulier une condamnation pour un
infirmier professionnels de santé aussi
de 700000 euros se fonder somme assez
conséquente
non ce qui est ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que le dispositif d'investigation
il ya deux aspects ya l'investigation
suite un signalement et puis l
investigation sur la base de requêtes
statistiques
effectivement quand on en arrive à ces
sommes là c'est que tout d'abord c'est
un professionnel de santé qui émet un
comportement déviant
pendant plusieurs années c'est des
procédures qui parfois sont très longues
qui est passé entre les mailles du filet
pendant toutes ces années
non il n'est pas passé entre les mailles
du filet simplement la décision puisque
on part d'un an du gip et y avoir une
pénalité mais il peut y avoir surtout
une sanction pénale
donc le l'infirmier qui cite en exemple
effectivement nous sommes aujourd'hui au
stade de la sanction pénale
pourtant il était au delà du préjudice
tout à fait il a été suivi pendant
quelques années par la cpam des yvelines
mais c'est vrai que le dénouement de la
sphère est aujourd'hui devant devant le
magistrat
vous parliez de la durée d'investigation
ces sont des dossiers qui sont très
longs instruire alors c'est très très
variable d'un dossier à l'autre
effectivement on a vu dans le reportage
qui a 5 181 dossiers en une année qui
ont été traitées parfois cédé ce dossier
qui se traite on va dire deux jours de
travail allait effectivement une
investigation sur le terrain et puis une
enquête administrative
parfois il y en a d'autres qui sont très
très lo est à la fois en termes
d'investissements pour l'épreuve
personnel de l'assurance maladie mais
aussi longtemps donc là ce sont des
procédures qui dure depuis plusieurs
années qu'ils sont les agents qui
interviennent sur le terrain donc d
ancien inspecteur des directives
effectivement ce sont parfois des
anciens inspecteurs nous avons dans le
service de lutte contre les abus fauté
et fraude de l'asepam des yvelines un
ancien gendarme donc qu'effectivement
était déjà aguerris à ses méthodes
d'investigation sinon nous avons aussi
des enquêteurs qui sont des gens qui
connaissaient bien le domaine des
prestations versier et qui ont une fibre
fibre sur ces métiers l'arrêt donc été
recrutés sur ses métiers ça peut aussi
parfois surprendre et faire peur à ceux
qui sont on va dire de bonne foi mais
qui ont commis une erreur par une
alternance ou tout simplement parce
qu'ils étaient mal informés ils ont des
recours ils ont des possibilités de le
saisir
c'est tout à fait la difficulté c'est
que la grande majorité des assurés ou
des professionnels de santé respectent
les règles donc il n'en demeure pas
moins qu'un à une faible part qui ne les
respectent pas d'où l'importance de ces
actions parce qu'elle peut nous
permettre de montrer que l' usage
l'utilisation des deniers publics et
bien contrôlée par les organismes de
protection sociale tels que l'assurance
maladie mais qu'à côté de ça ce qui ne
les respectent pas font l'objet
d'actions qui peuvent aller jusque peu
de jeu comme j'allais dire jusqu'au
pénal mais ça qu'ils feraient une erreur
par une adversaire
ils peuvent avoir un recours alors tout
à fait une action commence par une
notification d'un du tout professionnel
de santé aux assurés peut répondre à
cette notification d'ailleurs parfois il
ya une révision à la baisse de lundi où
vient carrément une annulation de la du
si les arguments qui sont montrés sont
des arguments tout à fait recevable par
contre qu'il irait bien souvent des
quarts ou les arguments ne peuvent pas
être reçue une et ne font pas l'objet
donc d'une minoration de cette année
est-ce que vous avez tous les pouvoirs
tous les droits ou est-ce que
quelquefois il est compliqué
d'intervenir d'agir pour les pour les as
alors nous n'avons pas tous les pouvoirs
et où les droits bien sûr alors en
fonction de l'état du dossier au stade
aux se trouve effectivement un indu peut
aboutir à une sanction administrative
donc là effectivement le directeur de la
caisse a un pouvoir de ryad y en termes
de sanctions financières ça s'appelle
une pénalité financière
après avis d'une commission ad-hoc
représente tf1 avec des membres de des
assurés et des professionnels de santé
il ya comme je le dis de la sanction
pédaler dans le dossier passe dans les
mains du magistrat et il peut y avoir
des sanctions ordinale disciplinaire qui
cette fois ci sont gérés par le conseil
de l'ordre notamment suite un
signalement suivant souvent un
signalement qui est effectué par le
médecin conseil de la caisse
faudrait-il donner plus de pouvoir à ces
différents agents qui interviennent pour
lutter contre les fraudes à la cpmc la
question que nous avons posée
aujourd'hui tout simplement
oui bon je pense que c'est mieux qui se
dit un peu plus pourquoi ben parce que
je trouve que c'est quand même c'est
important
e
de mieux contrôler toute façon toutes
les fraudes qui peut y avoir quoi quelle
qu'elle soit pourquoi pas mais ça dépend
jusqu'où aller pour entrer dans
l'intimité des gens quand même oui moi
je pense oui oui s'ils peuvent pas
exercer leur travail dans de bonnes
conditions ça sert à rien donc il faut
leur donner les moyens à plusieurs
contrôles sur les gens qui sont en arrêt
maladie oui je jouais pas plus de
pouvoir je sais pas que de quel pouvoir
ils bénéficient actuellement
moi je pense que les choses doivent
doivent être sans doute fait plus
intelligemment qu'elles ne le sont
aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que plutôt que chercher la
petite bête sur des choses qui sont pas
forcément des fraudes mais qui peuvent
être peut-être sans doute vus comme des
des détournements entre guillemets
peut-être chercher sur des choses à soi
des sondés
des vrais frau de plus plus
intelligemment fait et c'est quoi dans
l'opinion publique on comprend en tout
cas sur les gens que nous avons
rencontrés devant la caméra il nous
explique comprendre les investigations
que vous menez et pourquoi pas à voir si
plus de pouvoirs pour agir
en 2004 il ya une réforme de la sécurité
sociale avec des nouvelles sanctions
notamment possible
ça a été efficace depuis 2004 oui c'est
vrai que en 2004 avec la réforme la loi
du 13 août ya eu effectivement tout
d'abord une prise de conscience de
l'importance de la gestion du risque ou
sein des organismes d'assurance maladie
parce qu'effectivement notamment en
période de difficultés économiques on ne
conçoit pas qu'il puisse y avoir une
mauvaise utilisation des deniers
alors c'est vrai que comme l'a dit ou si
l'une des personnes qui a été interviewé
dans le reportage
il s'agit pas non plus d'aller
s'immiscer dans la vie privée des
assurés
donc c'est toute la difficulté donc
c'est vrai qu'on ne traite absolument
pas de la même manière
une fausse je dirais une fausse
déclaration d'un arrêt de travail avec
un trafic de médicaments par exemple
avec les parfois des ramifications à la
fois régionale nationale mais aussi avec
des pays étrangers
les bandes organisées qui est tout à
fait tout à fait c'est là où il faut
alors bien souvent ça peut partir de la
même origine c'est à dire un signalement
sur lequel avec des travaux
d'investigation on arrive à trouver des
ramifications
d'où l'importance aussi du travail qu'on
nous mène aujourd'hui avec les
partenaires que ce soit les partenaires
des autres organismes de protection
sociale ou les autres caisses
d'assurance maladie puisque nous avons
des instances régionales sur ces deux
sujets un signalement ça veut dire qu'il
faut dénoncer alors fo et utg lancia
sion sont fréquentes
alors ces dénonciations sont régulières
nous les regardons attentivement
il ya beaucoup de dénonciation qui
aboutissent à des sanctions à des
actions et des indus il y en a d'autres
pour lesquels il n'y a pas de suites à
donner mais comme si vous venez sur une
mauvaise piste peut-être même pas
beaucoup son voisin donné des fausses
informations ou tafer alors on arrive on
arrive quand même à faire la part des
choses et il ya aussi beaucoup de
signalements qui n'aboutissent pas alors
au delà des signalements nous avons
aussi nos propres outils en interne qui
sont en fait des outils de détection
d'un tipi qui nous perd qui nous
permette égard à des chiffres d'affaires
importants ou à des nombre d'actes très
important de mener des investigations
sans que ça parte d'un signalement
alors juste pour terminer sur les
analyses ont une autre source de
signalements importante c'est aussi les
signalements interne puisque nous avons
nos propres restent nos propres
collaborateurs qui sont au contact
quotidien avec les assurés et qui nous
remontent parfois d atypique dans les
comportements des assurés qui viennent
dans nos accueils on va écouter à
présent un patrick negar et c'est le
directeur général de la cpam des
yvelines le mot de la fin sera pour lui
nous parle des économies qui ont été
réalisés au delà des fraudes vous avez
aussi les fautes et des abus qui sont
pas une fraude puisqu'il n'a pas
l'intention de nuire est là on récupère
au total 28 millions d'euros c'est
beaucoup plus si vous voulez c'est ce
qu'on appelle la régulation la gestion
du risque et là on a un service ceux qui
travaillent là dessus et on pourrait
mesurer effectivement le nombre de
personnes qui travaillent pour voir si
ça rapporte suffisamment alors on est
largement bénéficiaire
mais d'un autre côté je crois qu'il ya
une vertu d'exemple s'est montrée
confronte pas impunément un service
public non plus et que il ya la peur du
gendarme quelque part qui fait que ça
dissuade peut-être d'autres personnes
qui auraient pu frauder potentiellement
invité ce soir qu'il est nous francisco
merci d'être venu sur le plateau
directeur de la régulation de la ceppm
78 nous parlions des fraudes à la
sécurité sociale avec des chiffres qui
donnent parfois le tournis du simple
abus à la véritable arnaque qui nous en
avons parlé ce soir cet entretien est à
revoir également sur notre site internet
dès demain vendredi un matin comme
toutes nos archives en consultation
libre
merci à vous